the past week in bitcoin was kind of
quiet but we're gonna dig into some data
and talk about some of the main story
lines to understand why exactly are we
just chopping sideways don't forget that
these weekly update videos are brought
to you by ftx you can click on the link
in the description to learn more let's
jump right in and start to look at what
exactly is going on with the data in the
bitcoin market first we can see that
bitcoin trading just above twenty
thousand dollars if we go ahead and we
take a look at the network and the
health of it see that the bitcoin market
cap is below 400 billion dollars the
inflation rate still fixed at one point
seven six percent and more than ninety
percent of all bitcoin is already in
circulation the real exchange trading
volume over the last 24 hours is sitting
just below seven billion dollars and the
miners have been paid just over 19
million dollars in the last 24 hours to
continue to secure the bitcoin
blockchain gbtc now trading at a 30
discount and bitcoin down about 70 from
its all-time high of 69 000 back in
november of 2021. if we compare bitcoin
gold in the s p 500 bitcoin is down 56
from a year ago gold down three percent
and the s p 500 down eight percent but
over a two to ten year time frame
bitcoin continues to out compete those
other assets bitcoin's price closing
history shows that bitcoin has only
traded above this point for 590 days
meaning that 88 of the time if you
bought bitcoin and held till today you
would be in the money
bitcoin compared to gold s p 500 nasdaq
and tlt saying the exact same story it's
been saying over the last few weeks the
compound annual growth rate sitting at
113 which is quite impressive compared
to those other assets and the sharpe
ratio coming in at 0.84 meaning that if
you add bitcoin to a portfolio it has
incredibly positive impact now the big
story over the last week was definitely
the federal reserve the united states
central bank continues to talk about
quantitative tightening they continue to
try to aggressively raise interest rates
and they have a mission to destroy
demand now as we have seen since
november of last year every single
trader everyone on wall street they were
putting bitcoin in the risk asset bucket
as they saw the federal reserve start to
talk tough about destroying demand and
increasing the financial conditions in a
tighter way they started to sell those
risk assets and bitcoin suffered along
with all other assets as well
now we see the federal reserve which has
raised those interest rates at an
aggressive pace still dealing with
persistently high inflation
just yesterday in the federal reserve
press conference from jackson hole we
saw jerome powell talk about a very
hawkish view
regardless of whether you think that
jerome powell and his crew actually have
the stomach to continue to create
tighter financial conditions or not one
thing is true the federal reserve is in
control and it's all one big trade right
now now if we go and we look at
international markets we can see that in
places like estonia that already have 20
plus percent inflation and we now have
predictions of double-digit inflation
coming to the uk and many other markets
it is very obvious that individuals are
going to look around and try to find
store value assets that can hold out in
these high inflationary environments
usually those assets will be something
with a fixed supply or something that
cannot just be created out of thin air
real estate precious metals and things
like bitcoin all come to mind now of
course bitcoin's price is just going
sideways it has now for a number of
weeks
one argument is that's a positive is
that simply bitcoin is just not
responding to any of the persistently
high inflation and is also not
responding to the tighter financial
conditions that they continue to try to
create here in the united states another
argument is that in this environment
some people thought bitcoin would
explode upwards but really my view is
that bitcoin is simply moving towards a
correlation closer and closer to one
with other assets and you see this
across the market real estate coming
down bitcoin coming down stocks coming
down this is what happens when the
federal reserve destroys demand that
demand is on the consumer side in an
effort to get inflation down but it also
is from investor appetite as well there
is no ability from the federal reserve
to create a difference between investor
appetite and consumer appetite it's
either we have a big appetite or we
don't as a society and if the federal
reserve is going to destroy consumer
demand they're going to destroy that
investor demand as well that's exactly
what we've seen and so whether people
like it or not there's not much to
analyze around bitcoin itself it's all
about the federal reserve will they
pivot or will they not that is the
trillion dollar question based on the
press conference yesterday it looks like
jerome powell he's still pretty hawkish
and he remains committed trying to be
paul volcker back from the 1970s my
guess is they can't really destroy that
much more demand and so at some point
over the next six to 12 months they will
pivot when that pivot occurs bitcoin and
other assets will likely benefit from
the tailwind caused by injecting more
liquidity into a market what that means
is that you need a hedgehog just hold on
don't get liquidated don't make any dumb
decisions
as the timeless financial principle
we're trying not to look stupid comes
from charlie munger and warren buffett
if you can successfully avoid being dumb
right now and simply holding for the
long term it'll likely prove to be a
pretty smart decision i hope that these
weekly updates are helpful to you it
makes me really stop and think more
about bitcoin the market and where
exactly we are
unfortunately all eyes remain on the
federal reserve that's just a sign of
the times these weekly updates are
brought to you by ftx if you're
interested in buying bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies you can go there
they're usually pretty cheap fees
sometimes as much as 85 cheaper than
their competitors they also have
introduced digital stock trading which
means that you can buy stocks in the
same place you buy your cryptocurrencies
on top of that they have no transaction
fees and no payment for order flow for
those stock orders so it gives you
better pricing go check them out today
by clicking on the link in the
description ftx and ftx us continue to
innovate in financial markets i'm glad
they're sponsoring these weekly updates
that's it for this week i hope these are
helpful and i'll see you guys again next
saturday